everybody I'm backstage here with Carol
Leifer amazing funny and the Kings just
one amazing you were fantastic on real
time everything is going super well
right now my parents the Kings how much
better time if I don't screw it all up
but you wrote this book idea how to
Succeed in Business Without Really
crying lessons from a life in comedy and
I don't know if you know this but Bill
Maher has a little boy carol has seen
and done it all and lucky for us she was
taking notes so this is a bill approved
book together right definitely check it
out yes did you have a book like this
when you were starting out I didn't and
that's exactly why I wanted to write the
book I wanted a book that would you know
when I was thinking about writing it it
became a memoir and then I was thinking
how I learned that from this experience
oh this came across to me from that
experience and I thought instead of just
an ego inflating memoir let me write
something that people can leave and also
you know share the wealth of my many
years in the business and in any
business I think it can really help
anybody who wants to approach a career
that's a super nice thing to do and you
were you trail blazed in a lot of ways
you're not a lot of female comedians now
there's a lot more now do you think it's
still the same sort of novelty act that
you kind of described it as well it's
still yeah you know to see a woman on
stage but that's what I love about women
and poverty I got on a lot more when I
started out because it was a way more of
unique to have women on stage but the
beauty of it and then I talked a little
bit about it on the show tonight when
you talk about women see the world in a
different way we have a different
perspective on things and when you talk
about that on stage
writing it really connects with people
my big advice is use what you have I
mean if you're a woman use your
femaleness whatever kind of quirky
strengths you have use that in the
workplace and that will get you far I
got to figure out what that is
soon I'll use my few maleness I feel
like it don't use that every night yeah
we need to keep it for ourselves the
storylines that you guys write are so
important I mean you worked on a lot of
really great shows Seinfeld for one
Modern Family as an L and the sort of
things that you talk about I mean that
[ __ ] was like Will & Grace
I feel like pushed along the movement a
lot absolutely do you think there's
another topic that needs to be written
about in the same way that never shows
about yeah it will be interesting to see
what the next thing is I mean I think
where Will and Grace started kind of the
revolution Modern Family has kind of
taken the baton you know in watching
Mitch and Cam's relationship and them
getting married and especially to men
because something about to gain women
that is more palatable you know to
audiences out there that I think is a
little tougher with two gay men so I
think that's great because I always joke
about how when I came out you know
the biggest supporters that I had the
most supportive friends were my straight
male friends because they were like
Carol I want to hear everything
tell me oh yeah slowly I'm not sure what
the next thing is but that's what's so
exciting about television because I know
so many people who talk about Modern
Family and say my favorite couple on it
is Mitch you can't you know and for now
that they're gay or anything just
they're a better relationship yeah and
that's when you start to do that and you
start to see gay people or whoever
people as just like anybody else it's
really revolutionary and you are engaged
right to a lovely lady yes yes I am
you were married to a man maybe I was is
there any difference in wedding planning
with another woman I'm against you and
I'm doing so what are you thank you um
well there's the thing you know in a
certain way my partner at glory is a
little bit like a dude because she's
like what see something simple and
expensive let's cut it out and I keep
trying to say to her you know just be
really like a girl with this can you
really girl it up and she refuses to so
we read a little bit of an impasse
because I would like a fancy kind of
girly wedding and she just wants to go
City Hall me and her get you know kind
of like do it and so that's tough I wish
I could say it was a little Olympic
event normally with the two women it
would be like that like there are Super
Bowl but it's not turning out that mine
is turning into this weird Olympic event
where my fiance is like
maybe you like cam it down a little yeah
yeah mix it up a little like I don't
know write what you have to figure out
the balance well good luck
thank you have a lot of fun with that
it's banned Carol Leifer everybody's
just fantastic
check out her book How to Succeed in
Business Without Really crying it's
fantastic